[Musique]
bonjour à tous il est 11h nous sommes en
direct sur l'antenne de Public Sénat
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle édition
100 % Sénat poursivre ce matin dans
quelques instants l'audition du
président de la FNSEA Arnaud Rousseau
président du principal syndicat agricole
qui est reçu ce matin par la commission
des affaires économiques du Sénat au
lendemain du discours de PO générale de
Gabriel Atal l'audition qui devrait
commencer dans quelques instants pour
l'heure en salle de commission c'est
Alexandre Sobo le président de France
industrie qui a la parole mais dans
quelques instants c'est Arna Rousseau
qui va prendre la suite de cette
audition mais je vous le disais il y
avait hier le discours de politique
générale du Premier ministre qui a
promis d'être au rendez-vous pour
répondre à la crise des écuteurs écoutez
un extrait du discours d'hier à
l'Assemblée nationale
gabrielal notre agriculture est une une
force et notre fierté aussi alors je le
dis ici solennellement il y a et il doit
y avoir une exception agricole française
je suis
lucide je suis lucide face à
l'empilement des normes face aux
décisions qui tombent d' haut et qui
parfois tombe Donon ne sait où
l'agriculture doute elle aussi et elle
attend des réponses et des solutions
nous serons au rendez-vous sans aucune
ambigué parmi les réactions politiques
écter celle du chef de fil des sénateurs
LR c'était ce matin chez nos confrères
de
TF1 des aides ça n'est pas ce qu'ils
veulent ils veulent un changement de
logiciel l'exception française la seule
exception française que les agriculteurs
connaissent aujourd'hui et que je
connais moi qui habite la ruralité qui
suis entouré d'agriculteur c'est
toujours plus de normes toujours plus de
transposition ce qu'il faut c'est un
changement de logiciel je m'explique ça
tombe bien le gouvernement dit qu'il va
y travailler il va y travailler mais il
aurait fallu qu'il affirme par exemple
que on mettait fin à toutes les
surtranspositions pourquoi est-ce est-ce
que il y a des mollécules interdites en
France qui sont autorisées ailleurs en
Europe voilà les annonces du
gouvernement les annonces de Gabriel
hatal d'hier vont-elles calmer la colère
des agriculteurs c'est tout l'enjeu de
l'audition qui va intervenir dans
quelques minutes sur l'antainne de
public Sonnage je vous le rappelle il
est 11h3 et nous attendons dans quelques
instants l'audition d'Arnaud Rousseau le
président de la FNSEA en salle de
commission des affaires économiques pour
l'heure c'est le précédent intervenant
qui a encore la parole mais donc en
quelques instants c'est Arnaud Rousseau
qui va pouvoir s'exprimer dans la salle
de la commission des affaires
économiques mais déjà tous les yeux se
tournent vers Bruxelles où doit se tenir
demain un Conseil européen voyez les
réactions politiques à ce discours avec
Fabien RER il était attendu sur le sujet
sans surprise Gabriel hatal s'est
beaucoup adressé aux agriculteurs hier à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a et il doit
y avoir une exception agricole française
une exception
contre la concurrence déloyale notamment
au niveau européen le Premier ministre a
aussi promis de poursuivre la
simplification administrative produire
c'est d'abord donner du temps à nos
agriculteurs pour passer plus de temps
dans leur champ moins de temps devant
leurs écrans produire c'est être
souverain je souhaite que cet objectif
de souveraineté alimentaire soit
désormais clairement inscrit dans la loi
Gabri annoncé un renforcement des
contrôle et des amendes pour faire
respecter la loigalim par les
distributeurs iliis
différes a remoursement de tax sur le
carburant indemnisation contre les
épidémies dein fond d'urgence pour les
viticulteurs installés sur la 6 au sud
de Paris ces agriculteurs ne se montrent
pas convaincus on attend plus attend
plus il a pas parlé de mesur
opérationnell pour le monde agricole on
attendait le discours bien s
impatiemment de monsieural qui qui
devait mettre l'agriculture pardessus
tout et qui en fait au final n'a
absolument rien fait de ce que nous nous
cherchions dans notre département ce
matin le mouvement se poursuit les
agriculteurs se rapprochent de la
capitale et de leur cible le marché de
gros de ringis où des blindés de
gendarmerie ont été déployé les
syndicats annoncent également des
blocages autour de plusieurs grandes
villes notamment Toulouse et Lyon voilà
nous sommes en direct sur l'antenne de
Public Sénat dans quelques instants vous
allez pouvoir suivre l'audition du
président de la FNSEA reçu ce matin par
la commission des affaires économiques
du Sénat et au lendemain on le comprend
hein de cette déclaration de politique
gén de Gabriel Attal avec cette question
clé les mesures développées depuis hier
et la semaine dernière par le
gouvernement ont-elles suffit à calmer
la colère des agriculteurs on le voyait
dans ce reportage de Fabien rcker il y a
encore des mobilisation autour de Paris
notamment aujourd'hui le premier
ministre qui a précisé plusieurs
annonces qui doivent entrer en vigueur
dans les prochains jours je propose de
regarder les détails on parlait du
doublement des contrôles pour appliquer
les lois égalim avec avec 100
inspecteurs supplémentaires de la
répression des fraudes une vague de
contrôle sans précédent a dit Gabriel
hatal pour faire appliquer les lois
égalim 1 et 2 sur le prix et le revenu
des agriculteurs autre mesure la
deuxième vous le voyez le remboursement
des taxes sur le GNR le gasoil non
routier et ce à hauteur de 50 % dès le
mois de février a dit Gabriel àal à
l'Assemblée nationale autre date le 5
février un guichet unique pour la prise
en charge vétérinaire pour la maladie MH
cette maladie qui touche certains beauin
avec des indemnisations DESS fin février
et enfin toutes les aides de la PAC
versé au 15 mars le Premier ministre qui
a évoqué des filières comme la
viticulture ou des régions comme la
britagne qui vont faire l'objet de
mesure de plan d'aide spécifique dévoilé
aujourd'hui pour la viticulture ou dans
les prochains jours pour la Bretagne je
vous le rappelle il est 11h6 on attend
toujours le début de l'audition d'Arnaud
Rousseau en attendant que cette audition
ne commence en salle de commission
affaires économiques écoutez en longueur
ce qu'a dit Gabriel hatal au sujet de la
crise agricole c'était hier à
l'Assemblée nationale on revient en
direct dès que l'udition
commence je l'ai déjà évoqué j'y reviens
nous devons mener notre réarmement
agricole produire et protéger pour notre
souveraineté voilà mon approche depuis
2017 nous avons engagé ce combat de la
souveraineté et du revenu c'est le sens
des plans de filière des différentes
lois é Galim du varen de l'eau nous
avons débloqué 250 millions d'euros pour
trouver des alternatives au phyosan
c'est un effort inédit sur l'Union
européenne nous avons toujours été
moteur sur la réciprocité et les
closuses miroir et nous les ferons
respecter
produire
produire produire oui ça vous dérange
produire produire c'est d'abord donner
du temps à nos agriculteurs pour passer
plus de temps dans leurs champs moins de
temps devant leurs écrans produire c'est
être souverain je souhaite que cet
objectif de souveraineté alimentaire
soit désormais clairement inscrit dans
la loi protéger aussi protéger face aux
crises climatiques et sanitair
le gouvernement l'a toujours fait lors
du gel des sécheresses de la grippe
avière nous avons adopté un budget de
l'assurance récolte sans précédent avec
un budget historique nous continuerons à
le faire protéger face à la concurrence
déloyale c'est le combat pour la
réciprocité et pour les mesur miroir que
je vais continuer à mener avec
détermination ce combat il doit se mener
en Europe comme nous l'avons fait sur
les médicaments vétérinaires mais nous
devons aller plus loin changer de
logique j'assume de dire que tout ne
sera pas réglé en quelques semaines
j'assume de dire que les chantiers sont
complexes et que pour certains il faudra
y travailler encore j'assume aussi
d'apporter des réponses rapides partout
là où c'est possible très concrètement
sur egalim dès la semaine dernière 100
inspecteurs de la DGCCRF supplémentaire
ont commencé leur contrôle sur le
terrain qui seront deux fois plus
nombreux qu'auparavant c'est une vague
de contrôle sans précédent sur la
trésorerie des exploitants nous avançons
dès à présent dès février 50 % des
remboursements titicpe seront versés aux
exploitants soit 733 € par exemple pour
une exploitation utilisant 7000 l de GNR
dès la semaine prochaine 5 février
précisément un guichet pour la prise en
charge des frais vétérinaires concernant
la MHE sera ouvert il permettra de
verser les premières indemnisations dès
la fin du mois de février le taux de
prise en charge des frais vétérinaires a
été révalué à 90 %. d'ici le 15 mars
toutes les aides PAC seront versé sur
les compes bancairees des exploitants et
nous travaillerons avec les
régions
et nous travaillerons avec les régions
pour que les aide à l'installation des
jeunes agriculteurs puissent être versé
dans les prochaines semaines pour
certains cela fait plus d'un an qu'ils
attendent et la semaine dernière le fond
d'urgence Bretagne a été doublé sur la
simplification j'ai parlé du travail
tout à l'heure des 10 premières normes
du travail au niveau local nous allons
poursuivre et nous irons plus loin
encore et tout ce que nous pouvons le
faire faire dès maintenant nous le
ferons d'ors et déjà je peux vous dire
que nous avons avancé ces derniers jours
dans la discussion dans l'échange avec
les agriculteurs et leurs représentants
sur une série de sujets sur l'élevage
nous avons mis en œuvre un dispositif
fiscal qui leur permet qui doit leur
permettre de faire face à l'inflation
notamment sur les prix de leur bêes nous
le renforcerons pour protéger toujours
davantage nos éleveurs sur Galim là
c'est très clair j'ai déjà parlé des
amendes et des contrôles mais je peux
vous dire que toutes les les amendes qui
seront infligées à l'industrie et à la
grande distribution seront utiliser pour
soutenir financièrement nos
agriculteurs sur la
viticulture sur la viticulture oui nos
viticulteurs souffrent mais notre
filière viticole et notre fierté elle
fait rayonner la France et donc je vous
annonce que nous allons développquer
dans les prochains jours des moyens
nouveaux avec un fond d'urgence avant la
fin de la semaine pour soutenir nos
viticulteurs particulièrement en
ocitan sur les contrôles je lance
aujourd'hui un grand plan de contrôle
sur la traçabilité des produits
l'objectif est clair garantir une
concurrence équitable notamment pour que
les normes qu'on applique aux
agriculteur soit aussi respecté par les
marchandises étrangères au niveau
européen nos trois priorités immédiates
sont claires les jchers les importations
ukrainiennes notamment de volaill et le
mercosour ces sujets seront portés et
sont portés très fortement par le
gouvernement et le président lui-même
nous nous sommes engagés nous avons
engagé une coalition de 22 pays sur la
question déjà cher et nous sommes
proches d'aboutir à une nouvelle
prolongation de la dérogation nous ne
nous laisserons pas faire nous prendrons
toutes les mesures pour éviter toute
surtrposition d'où qu'ell viennent je le
sais nous ne sommes pas au bout du
chemin il y aura de nouvelles conquêtes
dans les jours qui viennent je pense
notamment aux jeunes agriculteurs à la
transmission des exploitations mais nous
agissons vite fort avec détermination et
respect pour nos
agriculteurs voilà et l'audition
d'Arnaud haau que nous vous promettions
est en train de commencer voilà pour le
tour d'horizon de tout ce que l'on
pouvait dire autour du contexte dans
lequel se tient cette audition direction
à la salle de la commission d'affaires
économiques la chambre des territoires a
senti croître au fil de ses nombreux
travaux que ce soit à travers le déclin
de la compétitivité de la ferme France
ou bien par le prisme encore trop tabou
du suicide en agriculture que nos
rapporteurs Françoise ferra et Henry
Cabanel avaient très justement qualifié
de DRAM silencieux les mots de notre
agriculture sont très nombreux manque de
reconnaissance voire agribaching voire
même action violente contre les
agriculteurs comme nous l'avons vu
récemment à Sainte Soline problématique
du revenu qui ne concerne certes pas
tous les agriculteurs mais une part non
négligeable la question des retraites
agricoles trop faible alors même qu'une
loi voté à l'unanimité censé permettre
un calcul sur les 25 meilleures années
n'est appelé a entré en vigueur qu'en
2026 fléo des normes et des
surtranspositions
franco-françaises qui mine notre
compétitivité et place nos agriculteurs
en situation de concurrence déloyale
avec nos parttenaires les plus proches
accord de libre échange qui trop souvent
ne rechigne pas à sacrifier
l'agriculture européenne encore
considéré comme secteur non stratégique
enfin ambiguitté française intenable sur
le Green Deal européen et sa déclinaison
agricole assurance d'une mort lente de
notre modèle agricole et de ce qu'il
reste de notre souveraineté alimentaire
face à cette sédimentation et c'est un
mot que vous employez très souvent
monsieur le Président de problématique
il est peu de dire que le gouvernement a
fort àaire le Premier ministre a tenté
vendredi dernier de séduire les
agriculteurs promettant de mettre
l'agriculture au-dessus de tout très
franchement nous n'aurions pas pu mieux
dire en tout cas sur le diagnostic qui a
été dressé en revanche nous auurons
certainement pu mieux faire et la
déception et il faut bien le dire à la
hauteur de la force de de ces mots mots
mots quelques mesures de bon sens certes
sur le GNR ou encore sur les E mais où
est la vision 10 mesures
technico-administrativ et puis s'en va
ou du moins essai puisque les
agriculteurs n'ont pas été dupe et que
la mobilisation se poursuit plus que
jamais et pas plus tard qu'hier lors de
sa déclaration de politique générale le
Premier ministre a annoncé vouloir une
exception agricole française encore une
fois on ne peut que saluer l'ambition
tout en restant dubitatif sur les
traductions concrètes qu'emporteront
toutes ces déclarations d'amour à notre
agriculture au sein de notre commission
nous l'avons déjà dit et je rends
hommage au travail de la précédente
présidente Sophie prima puisque bon
nombre de ces travaux que j'ai cité ont
été faits sous sa présidence si le
Gouvernement entend travailler
sérieusement au redressement de la ferme
France une proposition de loi
transpartisane votée ici au Sénat est
toujours sur la table puisqu'elle n'a
pas été inscrite à l'ordre du jour de
l'Assemblée nationale elle ne règle
peut-être pas tous les problèmes mais je
pense qu'il s'agit là d'une base de
travail solide fruit d'une concertation
avec le monde agricole je m'arrête là
bien évidemment pour vous la parole
monsieur le Président pour que vous nous
indiquiez comment vous accueillez les
quelques annonces quelques annonces du
gouvernement et quelle suite vous
entendez donner à votre mobilisation qui
chacun le sait aura bien une fin mais
sur laquelle aujourd'hui vous êtes
particulièrement déterminé je vous
laisse la parole je précise que
l'audition est captée et diffusée en
direct sur le site internet du Sénat et
la vidéo sera ensuite disponible en
vidéo à la demande et je demande bien
sûr à nos collègues qui ne vont pas
manquer de vous poser de nombreux
questions d'être très concis et d'éviter
les questions redondantes merci monsieur
le Président je vous laisse la parole
très
volontiers merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente et bonjour à tous merci de
l'accueil qui m'est réservé ici dans
votre commission à votre invitation pour
parler à la fois de l'agriculture
j'avais déjà eu la chance d'être invité
devant vous il y a maintenant quelques
mois avec un diagnostic qui me
semble-t-il nit pas très loin de de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui et puis donc
évidemment l'idée de de vous décrire ce
qui se passe je voudrais peut-être
commencer par parler de la vision parce
que je pense que c'est ça qui est le
plus
intéressant la vision elle est assez
simple on est dans dans dans le pays qui
est reconnu comme étant celui qui a une
des agricultures les plus durables au
monde
euh ça veut pas dire que par ailleurs on
n pas des progrès qui doivent continuer
à être réalisés mais enfin faisons le
constat que quand on regarde ce qui se
passe ailleurs dans tous les autres pays
de la planète on est
finalement avec capacité de production
dans des conditions économiques
environnementales et sociales qui sont
reconnu comme étant les plus élevés de
la planète premier élément ensuite on a
clairement un monde dans lequel on est
dans un milieu ouvert donc on a des
échanges on a qui sont par ailleurs
nécessaires mais j'aurais peut-être
l'occasion d'y revenir si certains
d'entre vous ont des questions et des
questionnements forts d'un secteur
agricole qui est aujourd'hui un secteur
d'ajustement je crois qu'il faut être
capable de de le dire avec
aujourd'hui moins de 400000
exploitations agricoles professionnelles
c'est 100000 de moins qu' a en 2010 et
sur ces 400000 exploitation 100000 font
moins de 25000 € de production brute
standard dit autrement elles ne
permettent pas aux agriculteurs qui qui
sont inscrits dans cette catégorie de
pouvoir en vivre ce sont ça peut-être
des doubles actifs ça peut-être des gens
qui font autre chose on sait que
sociologiquement on aura près de la
moitié de la population agricole à
renouveler en tous les cas la moitié
d'entre elles partira en retraite dans
les 10 à 12 ans et c'est en tous les cas
166000 exploitants dans les 5 à 7 ans
c'est ce sont les chiffres officiels
voilà un peu le le décor le tout dans un
contexte où évidemment les sujets de
compétitivité de défi climatique de
sujet de décarbonation sont autant de
challenges à relever qui pour
l'agriculteur évidemment sont des soucis
quotidiens un agriculteur on a
l'habitude de le dire la sea c'est
d'abord un entrepreneur quelle que soit
la taille de son exploitation quel que
soit son son territoire quel que soit
son type de production et donc par
définition il a besoin à la fin de
l'année que son entreprise comme toutes
les entreprises que ce soit un
commerçant ou un artisan dégage du
revenu pour permettre de continuer à
rembourser les investissements à pouvoir
préparer les projets à pouvoir manœuvrer
évidemment à vivre et le constat
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a des écarts de
plus de plus en plus
important en agriculture enfin le cadre
donc la mission reste la même produire
pour nourrir c'est c'est ça je crois qui
est attendu on peut avoir des
contributions annexes celle de produire
de l'énergie renouvelable demain on sait
qu'on aura dans le cadre de la
planification écologique des sujets de
bouclage de biomasse sur lequel
l'agriculture est attendu et pour lequel
aujourd'hui on a un certain nombre de
réponses qui ne sont pas qui ne sont pas
là c'est pas de la mauvaise volonté
c'est que on sait pas boucler la
totalité des chaînes c'est en toutous
les cas ce qu'on travaille avec le
secrétariat général à la planification
écologique et puis au dehors donc de de
cette apport de volet énergétique donc
je parle je pense à la biomasse ce qu'on
peut faire avec le photovoltaïque sur
les toits notamment nos élevages mais
demain l'agrivoltaïsme puisque il y a un
projet qui est sur la table la
méthanisation peut-être d'autres
solution demain on a on aura en tous les
cas un élément de réponse au mix
énergétique puis enfin
ce qu'on appelle le volet des aminités
positives comment demain on pourra être
rémunéré pour notre contribution à la
décarbonation il existe deors et déjà
des propositions elles sont à ce
stade pas très développé mais enfin ça
existe et aujourd'hui un agriculteur qui
est capable de prouver que son sol va
stocker plus de carbone peut en avoir un
produit et on peut imaginer demain que
d'autres paiements pour services
environnementaux soit aussi un
complément de revenu donc produire pour
nourrir évidemment pour le faire j'ai
dit qu'il fallait du revenu et puis il
faut aussi des conditions de production
et je voudrais en dire un mot ça
m'amènera à ce quel cadre d'abord dans
un cadre européen puisque vous le savez
l'essentiel des politiques publiques
conduites sur le sujet agricole sont des
politiques européennes alors en premier
le dquel la politique agricole commune
mais ça n'est pas la seule politique qui
vient sur le champ agricole avec des
sujets évidemment de de de de contexte
européen de plus en plus de de
surtransposition et en tous les cas de
subsidiarité qui conduisent bien souvent
à de la surtransposition pas de manière
systématique un volet national et puis
ensuite des conditions d'échange donc là
je veux faire évidemment
mention des accords internationaux alors
là aussi je voudrais être clair la
France agricole ne peut pas se passer de
continuer à échanger qui imagine demain
la viticulture concentrée sur le marché
national c'est sa fin programmée et
immédiate qui imagine que sur le champ
des céréales à un moment où on est dans
une taille géopolitique avec notamment
la Russie et l'Ukraine sur le continent
africain on puisse passer de la
production et puis je pourrais vous
parler des produits laitiers transformés
et d'un certain nombre de d'autres
produits par ailleurs comme toujours on
peut avoir des intérêts offensifs et
défensifs et c'est vrai que sur les
intérêts qu' qu'on souhaite protéger on
a notamment la question de l'élevage je
faudrais en dire un mot parce que c'est
évidemment
central notamment dans les sujets de
planification écologique tout le monde
nous dit que la prairie
quelque chose d'essentiel puisque sur le
plan de la biodiversité sur le plan du
carbone c'est un levier important mais
par
ailleurs on constate tous les jours que
conserver notamment des bovins que ce
soit en lait ou en viande c'est
compliqué pour les éleveurs je le dis il
a quand même un moment où on pourra pas
avoir des prairies d'un côté et rien à
mettre dessus ça n' pas la prairie a une
fonctionnalité c'est de nourrir un
troupeau voilà et donc du coup il y a
tout un tas de de sujets qui qui qui se
posent sur cette question là un moment
où où ça décapitalise beaucoup voilà
donc ces conditions d'échange qui prévoi
qu'on puisse importer notamment de la
viande bovine mais je vous pourrait vous
parler des ovins dans des conditions de
réciprocité qui questionnent le monde
agricole interroge je le dis c'est pour
ça que j'essaie de rester équilibré
devant vous en disant on peut avoir des
intérêts offensifs et il y en a dans
d'autres secteurs mais ce qu'on constate
c'est que souvent dans les accords
commerciaux la question agricole
vis-à-vis des pays avec lequels on on
veut passer des accords la question de
l'agricul culture est souvent une
monnaie déchange l'Europe est plutôt
exportatrice de biens et services de
produits manufacturés et et les produits
qui veulent signer avec nous les pays
qui veulent signer avec nous des accords
ont plutôt de de de des produits
agricoles ou tous les cas du secteur
primaire amener donc il faut qu'on on le
regarde et c'est là où on dit que on a
un sujet de de règles et de normes alors
je lis beaucoup de choses en ce moment y
compris beaucoup d'excès nous n'avons
jamais dit que il fallait pas de norme
la norme elle est même capable parfois
de N nous protéger donc j'évite les
excès mais je dis que malgré tout il y a
un certain nombre de choses qui ne sont
pas comprises et qui se traduisent par
de la surtransposition ou des choses qui
qui nont pas je vous prends un exemple
parce que après tout il faut quand même
être un peu concret aujourd'hui et c'est
des remonté parce qu'en ce moment tout
remonte là mais voilà en production
ovine quand vous avez deux moutons qui
sont dans la même stabulation donc il
peuvent se toucher ça pose pas de
problème mais si si vous une fois par
vous tondez votre mouton la laine qui en
ce moment est un marché très déprimé qui
trouve peu de débouché que voulez la
garder la broyer et la mettre au sol
pour faire une litière bien c'est
interdit parce que la laine c'est un
déchet aujourd'hui au sens de la
réglementation voilà bon exemple est un
parmi d'autres mais voilà
l'agriculteur voyz c'est des choses
qu'il a du mal à comprendre pour des
raisons sanitaires essentiellement
concernant la laine je pourrais multiper
exemples je voulais vous dire pourquoi
un moment ça questionne alors je le dis
tout ça est une question vous avez bien
fait madame la président de le préciser
de sédimentation c'est-à-dire que ce qui
se passe en ce moment est le cumul de
règles de normes qu'au début vous
acceptter de de de voilà ça ça Râ un peu
mais bon et puis un moment quand quand
vous êtes arrivé dans le trop plein et
bien ça déborde et et c'est le moment
dans lequel on est et je le dis pour
l'ensemble de mes collègues agriculteurs
qui sont en ce moment sur un certain
nombre de points en France l'attente est
énorme l'attente est énorme et peut-être
même audà là de ce que on imagine avec
évidemment des sujets très nationaux
donc ça voilà mais beaucoup de sujets
européens et et je le je l'ai dit depuis
quelques jours en responsabilité sujets
européens ce ne sont pas des sujets qui
se règlent en 3
jours sur voilà donc je je j'essaie
d'appeler au calme et à la raison on
aura aussi je veux le dire devant cette
assemblée parce que c'est votre rôle un
certain nombre de sujets d'ordre
législatif à pouvoir faire évoluer et
notamment dans le cadre de la ploa la
fameuse projet de loi et d'orientation
agricole dont on rabat les oreilles des
agriculteurs
depuis de long mois oui vous nous avez
promis le passage devant les assemblées
avant enfin au début 2023 puis après
l'été puis à la fin de l'année puis au
début de l'année puis là le Premier
ministre nous a indiqué qu'il souhaitait
prendre quelques semaines
supplémentaires pour pouvoir compléter
le texte ce qui est plutôt une une bonne
nouvelle alors nous on voudrait vous
dire ce qu'on veut y voir bon et
évidemment ce qu'il y a aujourd'hui avec
les éléments d'installation et de
transmission qui est important comment
on transmet les entreprises et
aujourd'hui l'entreprise agricole ne se
transmet pas dans les mêmes conditions
qu'une industrie qu'une entreprise
industrielle et commerciale euh donc ça
c'est important comment on fait pour à
la fois attirer des jeunes les aider à
se lancer dans le métier et faire en
sorte que ceux qui quittent le métier
puissent le faire dans des conditions
dans lesquelles ils ont intérêt à le
faire et pas de dire je reste
agriculteur jusqu'à 70 75 ans avec tous
les sujets de pénibilité donc il faut
pouvoir accompagner ça on aura tout un
volet autour de la compétitivité alors
je le dis parce que je sais que cette
maison a travaillé il y a quelques mois
dans une proposition de loi
transpartisane à des sujets de
compétitivité alors est-ce que c'est
cela est-ce qu'on en ajoute d'autres
voilà je je je je laisse les
parlementaires faire leur travail mais
en tous les cas on a ces sujets très
clairement parce que dans le moment dans
lequel on est on a aussi un sujet de
compétitivité il faut accepter de le
dire voilà et puis enfin ce qui est
essentiel pour nous c'est d'y voir des
sujets autour de la souveraineté
alimentaire au premier rang desquels la
reconnaissance que l'agriculture est
d'intérêt général majeur voilà donc
après je ne suis pas juriste des gens
sont bien plus compétents que moi pour
pour traiter de ces sujets mais l'esprit
en tous les cas c'est ça et faire en
sorte que quand on prend des décisions
on puisse au moins
euh regarder ce qui est l'impact donc
nous on est très demandeur d'études
d'impact je le dis parce que notamment
on pourra peut-être parler du Green Deal
on a eu un certain nombre de de sujets
sur le Green Deal et et et les études
d'impact qui aujourd'hui montrent que
finalement le Green Deal est un échec il
est un échec pour les associations
environnementales hein il est un échec
pour pour la production et quand vous
voyez qu'au terme des 5 ans de ce mandat
à peu près toute l'Europe agricole est
dehors je suis pas persuadé que voilà
alors c'est pas que le Green Deal il y a
aussi des appareils et sujets de
fonctionnement on a eu un commissaire
euh européen à l'Agriculture qui de mon
point de vue n'était pas à la hauteur de
de de la tâche qui était la sienne euh
qui n'a pas permis de mettre cette
dynamique et d'essayer de trouver ce qui
de mon point de vue est son rôle espèce
de ligne de crête qui permet aussi de de
trouver des consensus en Europe voilà
donc ce sujet bah il est posé sur la
table nous serons en élection euh au
mois euh de juin et et et et les
Européens se se définiront je veux dire
aussi que dans le moment dans lequel on
est à la FNSA on a veillé à rester dans
le cadre professionnel je le dis parce
que les récupérations politiques euh ne
sont pas notre créneau à la fnsoa on a
des gens qui viennent de la gauche du
centre de la droite et et maintenant un
peu plus de l'extrême droite voilà mais
je j'ai pas de problème avec ça et et la
fnso ne prend pas de position politique
je le dis et on a veillé à ce que il y
ait pas de de récupération à aucun
moment en tous les cas moi j'ai été très
clair sur ce sujet mais
j'observe que il y avait la volonté de
de faire ça et je dis aussi que dans les
statuts de la fnsoa si on s'engage dans
un mandat politique en tous les cas
national ou régional on peut pas garder
ses responsabilités voilà donc dans le
moment dans lequel on est euh on a eu
d'abord une première phase qui a
consisté à être invité comme l'ensemble
des partenaires sociaux à rencontrer le
Premier ministre que nous avons fait
lundi il y a une semaine
voilà donc avec un échange qui
consistait à à poser le diagnostic moi
je j'étais très intéressé de savoir si
nous partagions le le diagnostic c'est
important de savoir si avant de démarrer
à travailler ensemble on est déjà au
clair sur ce que sont les éléments de
force et de faiblesse parce que je
voudrais quand même rappeler dans le
moment dans lequel on est que
l'agriculture a des éléments de force et
que s'il y a des menaces il y a aussi
des opportunités voà j'essaie de
regarder aussi comment demain on peut
continuer à à avancer donc on a posé le
diagnosticque avec le Premier ministre
et puis on en est resté là bon je
reviens pas sur ce qui s'est passé
vendredi le Premier ministre qui est
descendu en ocitanie qui a fait une
belle opération de communication qui
s'est finalement traduit par une forme
de
suragacement et puis qui nous a conduit
dans dans la la la la situation la
situation dans laquelle on on
est je dis aussi que beaucoup de gens en
ce moment critiquent la fnsoa euh je
pense que le le gouvernement est bien
content de nous trouver en ce moment
pour savoir avec qui négocier je le l
aussi très clairement parce que il y a
d'abord pas que la FNSEA d'autres
syndicats enfin euh chacun sera libre de
porter ses revendications j'ai compris
que le premier ministre recevrait les
autres syndicats en tous les cas pour ce
qui nous concerne après avoir fait des
remontées du terrain on a aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de propositions qui ont
été adressées au Premier ministre et sur
lequel on travaille donc on a eu des
séance de travail voilà donc le premier
ministre souhaite
aller le plus vite possible nous ce qui
nous intéresse c'est qu'on puisse
prendre point par point alors évidemment
en étant là aussi rigoureux entre ce qui
est franco-français sur lequel il a la
main ce qui est franco-français sur
lequel on a besoin du législateur donc
je je sépare bien ce qui relève du
décret de ce qui relève de de la loi et
puis ensuite on a des sujets européens
euh voilà qui ne se règleront pas en
quelques jours même si le président de
la République lui-même est à Bruxelles
aujourd'hui et et demain et puis enfin
on aura un rendez-vous électoral
européen dans lequel j'imagine que d'ici
cette échéance chacun portera les
visions et et les agriculteurs se se
définiront voilà peut-être ce que je
voulais vous dire en propos introductif
et je réponds bien évidivment à vos
questions merci beaucoup monsieur le le
président de ces premiers propos donc
vous imaginez bien que les questions
sont extrêmement nombreuses donc je vais
encore vous rappeler soyez concis précis
éviter de trop poser le débat aller
directement à la question à l'essentiel
et bien sûr si la question a déjà été
posée abstenez-vous de la poser ou
trouvezen trouvez-en vite une autre
alors on va prendre les
questions de franc Menonville de
Frédéric Buval et de Henri Cabanel oui
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président tout
d'abord vous dire que sur le le terrain
il faut vraiment souligner à la fois la
force de la mobilisation mais aussi
l'esprit de responsabilité des des
agriculteurs les manifestations et les
mobilisations se font dans dans le calme
avec une force de conviction mais avec
une un vrai esprit de de voilà de de de
de citoyenneté de responsabilité je
crois que vous en êtes d'ailleurs aussi
l'artisan moi je voudrais peut-être vous
dire vous vous avez évoqué donc ce que
vous souhaitez
voir être positionné dans la dans la loi
d'orientation agricole on voit bien que
la la difficulté de de de cette crise
c'est qu'elle vient de loin vous parliez
de de ses dientation elle touche à des
facettes européennes elle touche à des à
une érosion de la
compétitivité de l'agriculture française
liée à à une superposition de de
politique publique qu'on peut vraiment
aller aussi euh remettre sur les 20
années passées lois sur l'eau Grenelle
de l'environnement et autres où on a
demandé finalement à l'agriculture très
souvent de de répondre à des attentes
environnementales et sociétal et on sait
pas en même temps on n pas armé puisque
le président de la République aime bien
ce terme réarmer n'est-ce pas la
compétitivité de
l'agriculture et donc ma question elle
est simple qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
pour voir lever cette cette crise et ces
barrages en action et en proposition
immédiate pour répondre il faut le dire
davantage à du à du conjoncturel et
qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
voir engagé par le gouvernement et par
l'Europe sur des des mesures plus
structurelles pour
restaurer la compétitivité et la place
de notre agriculture merci Franck
Frédéric
Buval merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président euh je vous ai
écouté attentivement et je souhaite vous
assurer qu'en Martinique certainement
plus qu'ailleurs l'autonomie ou la
souveraineté alimentaire est un vrai
projet de société pour favoriser la
production locale et permettre à la
population de se nourrir convenablement
en quantité et en qualité en 2020 il y
avait 2680 exploitations agricooles à la
Martinique une baisse de 19 % par
rapport à 2010 les exploitants agricoles
ne demandent qu'à être plus accompagnés
pour produire plus et aussi répondre à
une demande locale envahie par des
produits d'importation de dégagement qui
sont devenus de et qui sont souvent de
mauvaise
qualité aussi tris trois pistes de
réflexion sur les problématiques de
l'ricultureemèire que je souhaite
soumettre à votre réflexion monsieur le
Président la première concneent les
spécificités du foncier de l'accès à la
terre entre les conflits d'usage les
contraintes environnementales climatique
ou juridique du fait de la division nos
exploitations sont plus petites plus
enclavées et donc souffrent d'un
sous-financement chronique pénalisant la
rentabilité économique du secteur et
donc à terme la création et la
transmission des exploitations la
seconde piste de réflexion se porte sur
les leviers de production et de
commercialisation adapté aux omes pour
cela je prends un exemple simple comment
aider les maires de Martinique qui sont
de bonne volonté mais qui ne parviennent
pas en dépit de la loi égalime a
proposer dans leur cantine des goyaves
ou autres fruits locales plutôt que des
pommes même si les pommes sont très
bonnes plutôt que des pommes en effet
les productions locales partissent des
coups d'entrant de production bien plus
élevés que de l'Hexagone oh là là
oui oui c'est desou des coups d'entr de
production bien plus élevés que de
l'xagone en raison deinement
géographique ces cours affectent
l'ensemble de la filière et limite les
débouchés commerciaux alors dans le
prolongement desction sur le TR de mer
c'est tout un plan
d'accompagnement que nous proposons pour
les filiers court et local la trè piste
porte sur l'adaptation des financements
des chambres
consulair ces entités sont souvent les r
interlocuteurs pour l'accompagnement
technique et administratif des
exploitants en effet comment accepter
quel que soit le montant réel des pertes
subies lors de catastrophe
naturelleinique tous les exploitants
reçoivent la même somme forfaitaire
aussi ma question est simple monsieur le
Président comment votre syndicat entend
porter les porter les besoins urgents de
simplification et d'accompagnement
attendu par les agriculturs
prabanel merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président comme l'a évoqué
la présidente dans ses propos liminires
nous avons été à l'origine d'un rapport
sur le mal-être des agriculteurs en
2021 je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails mais tout ce que vous
revendiquez aujourd'hui et tout ce que
les les agriculteurs rendiquent
aujourd'hui sur le revenu sur
l'agribaching sur la simplification
avait été bien spécifié mais je veux
juste revenir sur la première des
propositions qui était donc de faire de
l'avenir de l'agriculture une cause
nationale aujourd'hui le Président le
premier ministre a dit qu'il fallait
placer l'agriculture audessus de tout
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas pris cette
proposition pour vous et de nous aider
aussi à à la mettre en place dès 2020
dès 21 euh 2è question ne croyez-vous
pas qu'il est temps que les filières est
une véritable stratégie à la fois
nationale et et territoriale et et je
vais vous prendre un exemple sur une
filière que je connais bien la
viticulture je l'ai déjà dit ici mais je
vous le dis à vous euh comment peut-on à
la fois demander donc des primes à la
plantation comment peut-on à la fois
demander des primes à l'arrachage
comment peut-on demander l'accès à l'eau
et et et croyez-moi je pense que
dans un département comme le mien et
dans d'autres aussi l'éau il faut de
l'eau mais pourquoi pourquoi faire parce
que à même temps on demande donc des
primes pour la distillation donc je
pense qu'il faut qu'à un moment donné ça
soit clair dans la stratégie et et et
trème et dernière question qui était
éminemment importante et notamment par
rapport au projet de loi d'orientation
agricole sur le foncier aujourd'hui 2
ti3 du froncier disponible va à la grand
des exploitations et aujourd'hui quand
on sait que 50 % des installations se
font hors cadre familial on a besoin de
foncier comment pouvons-nous inverser
donc la tendance sachant que au niveau
des Saffire c'est quand même une mission
de service public et la première d'entre
elle c'est l'installation donc des
jeunes voilà monsieur le Président je
vous propose de répondre à ces tr tris
premières questions même si dans une
question il y en avait beaucoup
d'autres merci madame la Présidente je
vais commencer par répondre à la
question du du sénateur Menonville bon
sur les les discussions qui sont
actuellement sur le sur la table bon il
y a des discussions qui sont
francofançaise surt ce qui concerne
alors je vais prendre dans l'ordre donc
on pourra y revenir les sujets donc
ayant trait au au carburant à l'énergie
au GNR ça été annoncé il y a des sujets
et enentrit au coup du travail notamment
à la reconnaissance de des sujets autour
de te que qui est un sujet que vous vous
connaissez bien euh les sujets autour
des des filières je pense notamment un
grand plan autour de la viande bovine
qui est un un sujet de préoccupation au
moment où enfin je dis viande bovine et
est d'ailleurs au moment où on a une
décapitalisation du cheptel important en
France et et que je relie avec la
question des prairies que j'ai souligné
tout à l'heure on a des sujets
évidemment de de VTI j'y reviendrai tous
les sujets de surtransposition autour
des des phytosanitaires donc on pourra
parler du conseil stratégique on pourra
parler des des sujets de séparation des
sujets de d'instruments de mesure enfin
tout un tas de de sujets qui qui
questionnent les agriculteurs la
question de l'eau évidemment qui sera
aussi un sujet central j'ai discuter
récemment avec un certain nombre de
présidents de conseil départementaux je
pense notamment à la présidente du
conseil départemental de lariège qui me
disait qu'elle souhaitait pouvoir mettre
en œuvre un certain nombre de d'outils
de stockage d'eau avec de la maîtrise
d'ouvrage et qu'aujourd'hui la loi ne le
luit permet pas voilà donc c'est des
sujets typiquement sur lequel il faut
qu'on puisse revenir pour permettre que
encore une fois avec des modèles qui
peuvent être très différents parce que
celui de laariège n'est pas la même
chose que ce qu'on vit dans le
poidoucharante par exemple ENF en tous
les cas nouvellequitaine n'est pas la
même n'est pas du même tonneau et puis
ensuite des sujets européens dans les
sujets européens j'ai j'ai parlé de la
PAC mais il y a des sujets autour de la
directive industrielle qu'on appelle IED
dont une partie concerne l'agriculture
il y a d'autres sujets que l'agriculture
dans IED mais enfin il y a un volet
agricole et et le trilogue qui a abouti
il y a quelques semaines conduit à ce
que si on ne change rien en 2028 un
élevage de 21000 500 poules pondeuses
puisse être sur le même Parcher de
compétition que son homologue
ukrainienne qui a 1 million de voaill et
qui rentre aujourd'hui en franchise de
droit de douane voilà je je pose ça je
prends forcément le cadre un peu un peu
élargi mais je je veux que vous
compreniez ça et puis après on a les
sujets évidemment d'accords commerciaux
alors je dis pas que tous les accords
commerciaux sont remettent en cause mais
enfin il faut quand même qu'on regarde
les contenus celui qui défrait la
chronique en ce moment c'est plutôt le
le Mercosur dont on sait que ce qui gêne
dedans c'est les 99000 tonnes de viande
bovine supplémentaire qui rent je dis
supplémentaire parce qu'il en rendre
déjà près de 300000 tonnes donc voilà je
et le sujet c'est pas d'importer de la
viande bovine là aussi je voudrais qu'on
soit précis je lis beaucoup de de de
contrevérité le sujet c'est comment
c'est produit voilà on a du mal à
comprendre qu'un élevage moyen français
de viande bovine qui est d'environ 80
vaches alors plus la suite hein les
gunis c'est voilà soit comparé à un
fidelot sergentin ou brésilien je vous
invite à aller voir un jour si vous êtes
dans ces pays c'est entre 3000 et 5000
animaux c'est c'est voilà c'est c'est
c'est des sujet de décarbonation
importée pas systématiquement mais ça
mais ça peut-être voilà donc c'est ça
qui a qu'il y a derrière par ailleurs on
peut aussi avoir des intérêts offensifs
sur le Mercosur je je ne le ni pas j'ai
essayé de le dire tout à l'heure voilà
donc et puis enfin dans les sujets du
moment il y a la question ukrainienne
alors là aussi je vrais être très clair
parce que bon l'Ukraine est en guerre
l'Europe doit apporter son concours à un
peuple qui se bat pour sa liberté ses
frontières son modèle très bien bon donc
il y a pas de mal entendu mais l'Ukraine
est un grand pays agricole c'est à peu
près un/4 de l'Europe agricole dans le
moment dans lequel on est qu'on vienne
en aide aux Ukrainiens je pense que tout
le monde peut le comprendre mais ça
n'empêche pas de poser la question
agricole je vous donne quelques exemples
il est rentré il rentrait d'habitude
avant le conflit 20000 tonnes de sucre
ukrainien en Europe il en est rentré
l'année dernière près de 700000 tonnes
je pense que tout le monde comprend qu'à
un moment en terme de déstabilisation
des marchés il y a un problème bon
qu'est-ce qu'on dit nous on dit que il
faut qu'on trouve à partir de de clause
de sauvegarde la possibilité de faire
rentrer quelques volumes parce que après
en franchise de droit de douane parce
qu'après tout c'est pas c'est pas
choquant qu'on qu'on continue commercer
mais que le reste on regarde comment
éventuellement on peut faire des
corridors pour réexporter parce qu'on
comprend bien que les ports de la mer
Noire sont pas aussi disponibles mais ce
sujet il faut l'adresser et si vous
posez la question un agriculteur
polonais ou roumain il sera encore plus
déterminé que ce que je viens de de vous
dire donc le sujet c'est pas de tomber
dans les agriculteurs ne pensent qu'à
eux veulent pas se soucier de lucra il y
a une réalité de de marché voilà donc il
faut quand même qu'on la regarde parce
que ça se traduit derrière par des
fermetures de de de de d'outils sur tout
le territoire national voilà quand vous
avez une sucrerie et que vous êtes face
à ce sujet de compétition c'est c'est un
problème et et on pourrait le le
multiplier donc voilà ce sujet c'est pas
pour dire encore une fois l'Europe est
une île on veut rien faire mais on a
besoin de de le regarder et puis ensuite
il y a tout ce qui est sujet
simplification parce que là on peut en
faire alors il y on a donc plutôt une
bonne nouvelle annoncée par le Premier
ministre que de dire on se met autour de
la table tout le monde est invité dans
les préfectures et puis on on liste et
puis après on agglomère et on regarde ce
qui est rapidement faisable moi j'ai
envie de faire cet exercice il a jamais
été fait après est-ce que il donnera du
fruit ou pas je je veux pas voilà notre
rôle c'est de se mettre au boulot du
type de ce que je viens de vous éclairer
typiquement sur le GNR l'annonce qui a
été fait sur le pied de facture nous
paraî aller dans le bon sens voilà parce
que tout ce qui permet un agriculteur de
passer un peu plus de de temps à son à
son activité principale et un peu moins
à remplir des papiers va dans le bon
sens voilà donc ça on a envie bon j'ai
listé les mesures de manière rapide hein
mais voilà et puis après je le redis il
y a tous les sujets législatifs donc
installation transmission compétitivité
souveraineté
alimentaire je je je continue madame la
Présidente alors sur la question de du
sénateur du Val de de la Martinique bon
d'abord on n'oublie pas l'agriculture
ultramarine je le dis aussi parce que
j'ai eu nos collègues de la Réunion il y
a quelques jours qui après le cyclone
était quand même dans dans des
conditions
difficiles alors vous parliez je je vais
essayer d'être concret sur l'adaptation
du financement des chambres et des aides
voilà bah là on est typiquement dans le
cadre européen puisqueen fait le le
dispositif des minimis qui permet
d'apporter du soutien se fait dans un
contexte européen pour pas que ce soit
distorif et le déminimis aujourd'hui est
plafonné pour l'agriculture je dis bien
pour l'agriculture à 20000 € donc
aujourd'hui si on peut peut pas aller
au-delà des 20000 € monsieur le sénateur
c'est parce que le cadre européen ne le
permet pas voilà donc après je dis pas
qu'il faut pas un plafond hein mais là
aussi on demande à ce que ce plafond
puisse être augmenté il a été dans
d'autres secteurs d'activité donc c'est
c'est c'est c'est possible voilà mais
l'explication très concrète des raisons
pour lesquelles à un moment on peut pas
aller au-delà de 20000 € alors qu'il y
aurait des besoins bien supérieurs c'est
celui-là euh bon sur les sujets de
production et de commercialisation avec
les importations y compris de produits
voilà bon le cœur du sujet pour nous
avant la commercialisation c'est la
production ce que nous disent les
producteurs martiniquais je vais prendre
l'exemple de la banane que vous
connaissez bien c'est qu'aujourd'hui ils
ont un certain nombre de contraintte de
production notamment parce qu'ils ont
des maladies parasitaires du bananier et
que sur la circosporiose noire notamment
ils ont des problèmes de de production
donc il faut qu'on arrive à regarder
comment on peut continuer à avoir un
appareil productif qui nourrit et puis
ensuite vous posiez la question du du
débouché je je rappelle que dans le
cadre de la loi aujourd'hui euh on est
censé dans les cantines de Martinique
mais mais comme de de métropole d'avoir
50 % de production donc de qualité ou 20
% de bio ou siges de qualité et qu'on
sait aujourd'hui que les objectifs fixés
par le gouvernement à son propre sa
propre administration ne sont pas
remplis voilà je je dis ça quand même
c'est dire que moi je veux bien prendre
un certain nom de responsabilité
regarder ce qu'on peut faire mais il
faut aussi que tout le monde respecte le
cadre d'engagement donc le ministre de
l'Agriculture lui-même a dit qu'il
allait veiller à ce que puisse monter en
charge je sais aussi et peut-être les
élus ici le savent mais il y a aussi un
sujet quand même d'accès que quand vous
augmenter le prix de la cantine dans une
école c'est c'est vite un sujet de de de
discussion or voilà il faut qu'on
accepte de discuter de de de ces sujets
moi je dirais que le prix de la cantine
pas trop mon mon sujet mais comme il se
trouve que je suis é local j'entends
aussi ce que ce ce que les gens disent
et faut accepter que dans un
certainombre de cas ça puisse valoir un
peu plus cher pas beaucoup plus cher un
peu plus cher et que on peut aussi avoir
des produits importés à bas cout mais
qui ne remplissent pas ses ses objectifs
sur le foncier bon c'est pas qu'un sujet
ultra marin si je puis dire parce queil
y avait aussi la question posée par le
sénateur Cabanel mais sur le foncier
dans le cadre des discussion avec l'État
et ça me fera peut-être une transition
il y a aujourd'hui un ce qu'on appelle
un sdrea un schéma directeur
d'attribution des terres disponible avec
le l'installation en premier critère
voilà après on est dans un cadre alors
parce que vous parliez des safaires mais
il y a pas que les saffaires il peut
aussi se faire des affaires de gré à gré
la safaire n'est pas n'est pas
systématiquement présente il faut
d'abord que comme dans T les
transactions il faut que le vendeur et
l'acheteur se mettent d'accord
accessoirement et ensuite il y a des
critérisations donc c'est installation
ensuite c'est confortation et ensuite
c'est agrandissement c'est comme ça que
c'est prévu dans les schémas
départementaux après il s'applique ou il
s'applique pas il peut y avoir quelques
non mais je
je voilà je constate comme vous que
parfois il peut y avoir des euh des des
des sujets ça a été aussi renforcé dans
le cadre de la loi sans passous
euh qui prévoyait qu'on puisse aussi
contrôler les transmissions de part
enfin les transmissions partielles euh
de de de part sociale bon le sujet de
Fond euh c'est l'accè des terire c'est
aussi le modèle derrière ou les modèles
que que que que ça développe et et nous
ce à quoi on tient c'est vraiment la
possibilité pour l'agriculteur quelle
que soit encore une fois la production
le revenu territoire que il en vivent
c'est c'est ça qui qui compte pour nous
donc on a aussi des endroits aujourd'hui
où où le foncier trouve difficilement
preneur euh voilà il y a aussi des
sujets dans certaines régions très
spécifiques de de des prises
agricoles voilà donc je je regarde ça
aussi avec beaucoup de de de de recul
parce que quand vous avez comme dans
votre région des endroits où il a plus
moins de 100 mm ou 120 mm en une année
sur la question de la production ça pose
quand même des questions et que ce soit
la vigne même un olivier a besoin d'un
peu d'eau voilà donc je sais qu'on
travaille sur est-ce qu'on peut mettre
demain des amendier de la vigne voilà
mais il y a aussi ce ce sujet là donc
derrière le foncier il y a aussi la
capacité du foncier à dégager du du
revenu sur la filière
viticole bon on est très conscient de ce
qui se passe hein c'estd que à la fois
vous l'avez dit en 3 ans de agne de
distillation qui ont atteint des des des
des des sommets et pas seulement de de
vin on va dire standard mais y compris
de vin en AOC je pense à Bordeaux qui la
dernière fois a mis des quantités très
importantes a des tarifs je crois que
c'était 75 € lecto en aosé on peut pas
dire que ce soit rémunérateur et
pourtant des volumes ét là très
importants en ce moment le sujet c'est
pas tellement les aides à la plantation
en ce moment le vrai sujet c'est les
aides à l'arrachage et avec un débat y
compris à l'intérieur de la profession
en nétant pas vite culteur je je prends
la distance nécessaire mais entre
arrachage temporaire et arrachage
définitif chacun expliquant qu'il faut
le plus d'arrachage possible mais plutôt
dans les appellation des autres enfin je
je le
fais un peu rapide mais vous me
pardonnerez mais enfin il y a aussi un
peu ça bon aujourd'hui le sujet c'est
quel marché quelle segmentation et
quelle r commerciale parce qu'on a aussi
beaucoup de vin qui arrivent d'Espagne
dans des conditions d'importation et de
la franchisation qui parfois
questionnent bon donc là ce travail il
doit être fait rapidement euh parce que
la situation n'est n'est pas tenable euh
et d'ailleurs dans dans les actions qui
ont été faite depuis quelques jours là
où c'était le plus compliqué où la
colère était la plus grande c'était
souvent dans les zones viticoles euh
avec une tradition viticole que vous
connaissez probablement mieux que moi et
qu'on a vu ressurgir je pense à des
actes qu'on ne peut pas accepter euh
voilà donc euh en tous les cas pour ce
qui est de la FNSEA et de son volet euh
et de son action euh autour des sujets
de ticulture on est on est très au clair
sur la nécessité de de de regarder la
segmentation des progrès avaient été
enregistrés il faut aussi donner acte de
ce qui a été fait depuis 20 ans
notamment dans le langdoc après la
viticulture elle est plurielle parce
qu'on parle beaucoup du Langedoc de
Bordeaux mais les sujets sont pas les
mêmes si vous êtes en Champagne ou en
Bourgogne donc il faut aussi regarder ça
avec voilà je le dis aussi on avait des
des secteurs qui marchaient très fort je
pense notamment au cognac et qui
connaissent depuis quelques mois un un
frein important notamment
parce que l'exportation et notamment sur
le continent américain était très
largement voilà et comme toujours quand
vous avez des marchés qui sont qui
poussent beaucoup pouvait prendre
quelques mauvaises habitudes et quand le
marché se resserre de manière assez
brusque être en difficulté et je le dis
aussi parce que dans les primes à la
plantation le gros de la troupe
concernait cognac voilà près de 3000
hectar par an et donc je pense aussi que
là tout le monde va prendre conscience
qu'il faut être un peu raisonnable
pardon la veille de Oui Oui mais ou
aussi depuis 10 ans on implante
énormément euh énormément de de vigne et
évidemment le marché éant ce qu'il est
quand ça tire tout le monde en veut et
puis quand ça freine on sait plus quoi
faire des vignes donc il faut qu'on
trouve aussi les bons réglages
voilà alors rapidement si c'est possible
remémy Cardon Patrick Chauvet et Daniel
salmand merci madame la Présidente si je
j'en crois les chiffres du ministère de
de l'agriculture vous le savez mieux que
moi 25 % des agriculteurs dépassent des
revenus agricoles de plus de 100000 par
an et 25 autres en dessous de 30000 par
an bref certains gagnent de mieux en
mieux leur vie quand d'autres ont de
plus en plus de mal à boucler les fin de
mois alors monsieur le président de la
FNSEA puisque vous prétendez défendre et
je vous pense sinincère là-dessus
défendre le revenu des agriculteurs
coûte que coûte que pensez-vous de
plafonner les marges de la grande
distribution euh pourquoi vous ne le
revendiquez pas alors que nous savons
très bien c'est demandé et attendu par
la
profession merci Patrick
Chauvet Patrick Patrick Patrick pardon
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président merci de de votre Présence JE
SUIS sénateur de de Normandie
avec les mêmes questions qu'ailleurs je
crois et je reviendrai sur à volet qu'
me semble un peu oublié dans dans les
revendications que je partage et et et
ce qu'on entend finalement c'est ça
c'est ça s'est construit sur sans doute
20 20 20 à 30 ans je voudrais savoir
quel est comment vous vous voyez les
choses par rapport au ministère de
l'Agriculture moi j'ai le sentiment que
on a des ministres compétents de très
bonne volonté et ça aurait pas de sens
que de taper sur les hommes ou les
femmes qui qui prennent ces
responsabilités là mais que le ministère
n'a plus de poids parfois l'impression
que le ministre se bat d'abord en
interne avec d'autres ministères se bat
avec les agences au pluriel avec la Cour
des comptes rappelez-vous qui dit qu'il
y a trop de vaches mais qui oublie de
dire que si on diminue les vaches faudra
les acheter les produits ailleurs ou
alors faudra intensifier la production à
l'unité de des vaches laitières enfin on
entend plein de contradictions et du
coup ça matche déjà à l'intérieur de la
tête du de de ce pays donc on entend
peu aujourd'hui au travers toutes ces
revendications là comment on peut
repositionner un vrai ministère de
l'Agriculture qui puisse agir au lieu
d'essayer d'être tout le temps pris dans
les contradiction et contradiction inter
terne moi je voudrais aussi souligner
les les dégâts qui ont été faits en
communication tout à l'heure mon
collègue a évoqué l'agribaching moi
j'avais été à l'époque je je suis dit
mais qui a pu inventer cette chose
aujourd'hui on entend que les Français
soutiennent leur agriculture c'est assez
logique c'est l'agriculture qui qui qui
les nourrit mais rappele -v de l'agri
baching la traduction d'abord on a le
droit de parler français c'est c'est
tapé fort laagribaching on peut socio
professionnellement faire du baching
surtout on l'a vu sur les forces de
l'ordre on l'a vu sur d'autres
catégories socio professionales mais les
dégâts que ça a fait chez les
agriculteurs c'est c'est c'est terrible
le ressenti d'être comme ça le Bou
émissaire d'une société je crois qu'il
faut faire attention et qu'on prête pas
assez attention surtout aujourd'hui au
moment où on en est au côté humain aux
femmes et aux hommes qui travaillent en
culture moi j'entends beaucoup les
éleveurs on perd des éleveurs en
Normandie vous imaginez l'image sans
nostalgie d'un temps révolu de la
Normandie on perd des éleveurs laitiers
tous les jours en Normandie mais il y a
un peu tout ça il y a l'aspect des
filières vous vous en occupez très bien
il y a l'aspect des réglementations et
ça sera la fin de mon propos euh mais
qu'on remette l'humain au centre de nos
décisions au centre de la table sinon ça
tiendra
pas tout ne tient où que ce soit que
s'il y a des hommes et des des femmes
qui peuvent agir et et essayer qu'il
puissent agir en en sérénité vous avez
évoqué sur vous alliez vous mettre au
travail sur essayer de la simplification
je pense que la pire des choses ce
serait de de créer un ministère de la
simplification parce qu'on aurait tout
le contraire de de ce qu'on souhaiterait
je suis pas sûr et j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour les préfets que ce soit là
que ça se passe
euh je n'ai pas personnellement la
méthode mais je crois qu'il faut la
structurer différemment pour mettre en
évidence que là-dessus ce sera du bon
sens et tout le monde le reconnaîtra les
injonctions contradictoires parce que
personne ne s'y retrouve mais on peut
pas ma crainte c'est que demain ça
s'arrête et qu'on continue et qu'on
continue et qu'on remette des normes et
qu'on remette des superpositions
normatives et je vous rejoins vous avez
raison on a besoin d'un cadre mais je
suis pas sûr que au moment où tout cela
est très révélé dans la revendication et
à juste titre qu'on qu'on est mis en
œuvre ou qu'on prenne les moyens de de
résoudre ce problème là en agriculture
Merci à VOUS Daniel salement merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président le monde agricole est en
colère effectivement mais le monde
agricole est loin d'être homogène
aujourd'hui on a des énormes disparités
vous savez aussi bien que moi que 20 %
des agriculteurs captent 80 % des aides
de de la PAC et donc ça veut dire que
les 80 % autres se partagent les 20 % et
ce ne sont pas que des producteurs que
des agriculteurs improductifs qu'est-ce
que vous pensez votre syndicat est-ce
qu'il soutient toujours les aides à
l'hectare ou pensez-vous qu'il faut
vraiment moduler cela que pensez-vous
aussi le plafonnement à combien
mettez-vous le plafonnement des aides
aujourd'hui pour qu'on ait une vraie une
vraie redistribution au niveau des
agriculteurs dans mon département devant
il y a des eu des manifestations devant
une laterie devant du groupe
saventicia aujourd'hui c'est ces groupes
là font pression pour diviser les
agriculteurs ne respectent pas les
accords cadres que peut-on faire pour
que et bien il y a pas cette volonté de
de diviser pour mieux régner et toujours
faire baisser le prix de des mitres de
lait on sait pourquoi ça décapitalise
tout simplement parce que les agricul ça
décapitalise en beau vin tout simplement
parce que les agriculteurs n'y
retrouvent plus leur compte bien entendu
euh le libre échange dernière chose qui
qui qui vote les accords de libre
échange et où en est votre syndicat sur
ces accords de libreéchange je vois bien
que il y a des des positions un peu à
géométrie variable est-ce que on doit
pas avoir un cap un peu plus clair et
puis la résilience on tape beaucoup sur
les normes alors on parle d'agribashing
j'ai l'impression qu'en ce moment c'est
plutôt le décolo
bashing comment fait-on pour faire en
sorte que notre agriculture gagne en
résilience et soit propre à s'adapter au
réchauffement climatique merci voilà
monsieur le Président je vous laisse
répondre à ces questions merci je vais
commencer par répondre à la question du
ateur Cardon sur le sur les marges de la
grande distribution bon
d'abord moi je au moment où où je vous
parle je ne sais pas et donc j'ai
demandé à ce que le ministre de
l'Économie Monsieur le Maire puisse à
nouveau comme il l'avait fait il y a un
an et demi diligantter une enquête de
l'IGF l'inspection générale des finances
pour qu'on puisse avoir des chiffres
clairs parce que vous observez comme moi
que chacun explique que c'est pas lui
mais c'est l'autre et que il est
parfaitement en règle donc moi d'avoir
ces chiffres d'abord la première chose
c'est que j'espère qu'on va avoir un
transfert de marge vers vers
l'agriculture c'est c'est c'est ça que
je c'est c'est c'est ça mon boulot bon
voilà donc après je je je j'essaie
d'être équilibré là aussi tout le monde
a besoin de de vivre pour faire tourner
les entreprises donc ce qu'on avait
observé lors de la je vais parler des
derniers chiffres de l'IGF en attendant
les prochains puisque le ministre a dit
qu'on devrait les avoir sous quelques
jours ou quelques semaines bon donc en
tous les cas la dernière fois on avait
constaté qu'il y avait un transfert et
c'est bien ainsi il était largement
temps puisqu'on avait eu 10 ans de
déflation auparavant
euh donc sur ce voilà par ailleurs pour
être précis l'encadrement des marges je
je je je voilà sur le plan législatif je
je pense que c'est un peu compliqué il y
en a d'autres qui demandent
l'administration des prix voilà je pense
que ça c'est c'est pas raisonable
transparence mais c'est pas la même
chose que l'encadrement si je puis me
permettre voilà et donc la transparence
nous la demandons nous et et et en fait
il y a qu'une manière de la voir assez
rapidement c'est à travers l'IGF parce
qu'on a aussi un observatoire des prix
et des marges mais qui a toujours 18 à
24 mois de de retard évidemment ce qui
nous intéresse c'est c'est de pouvoir
regarder au monter ce qui nous intéresse
aussi avec la grande distribution et ça
c'est des demandes qu'on formule dans le
moment dans lequel on est c'est de faire
en sorte qu'il y ait pas de négociation
entre l'industrie agroalimentaire et la
grande distribution tant qu'il y a pas
eu un accord entre les représentants des
professionnels les organisations de
producteurs je vais le faire un peu
rapide et le monde et le monde de
l'industrie agroalimentaire ça me paraît
important dans la construction du prix
en marche avant ça nous éviterait aussi
ce qu'on a en ce moment c'est-à-dire un
certain nombre de grandes entreprises
qui nous disent moi au regard de ce qui
est la difficulté de la négociation que
j'ai avec l'industrie avec la grande
distribution je ne suis pas en mesure de
vous donner plus que voilà et et c'est
notamment le le cas dans le le lait
enfin voilà sans sans sans citer de
d'entreprise enfin concernant les
grandes distributions on a une
inquiétude parce qu'un certain nombre
d'entre elles se sont adapté à la loi
les Français font ça très très bien euh
et sont aujourd'hui en train de négocier
dans le cadre
européen voilà et et et du coup ce qui
nous intéresse c'est qu'on puisse
regarder comment cet esprit peut évoluer
pour ça on a besoin de l'évolution du
cadre européen donc il faut qu'on on
regarde ça et du cadre national donc ça
ça fait partie des des discussions qu'on
a l'esprit c'est pas que des produits
alimentaires puissent être négociés au
niveau européen pour arriver en France
et détourner le cadre de la loi c'est
bien qu'on soit dans l'esprit de la loi
je note depuis quelques jours une une
forme de bénévolence de la grande
distribution je m'en réjouis euh voilà
je je trouve que il faudrait qu'on
s'évite ce ce ce ce type de moment de
colère et qu'on puisse avoir un peu de
de
maturité il y a pas de naïveté dans mon
propos hein voilà mais pour nous la
question du prix elle est centrale voilà
je dis aussi que toutes les filières ne
sont pas encadrées par égalim voilà donc
je je je le dis pour pour qui peuvent
être des choix hein des filières
elles-mêmes euh voilà mais en tous les
cas quand on parle d'élevage euh qui est
le sujet qui nous préoccupe en ce moment
euh la question du prix elle est
centrale voilà et donc ça ça va être
regardé de de très très
près sur la question alors euh quel rôle
pour le ministère de l'Agriculture bon
écoutez moi je vais essayer de rester à
ma place hein euh voilà je moi j'ai
besoin d'un interlocuteur nous avons
besoin d'un interlocuteur euh on a
maintenant un ministère de l'Agriculture
et de la souveraineté alimentaire on
trouvait que le le signe était
intéressant enfin ce qui m'intéresse
plus moi c'est l'efficacité vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui le budget du ministère
est essentiellement consacré à
l'enseignement agricole et et et et
l'enseignement agricole attire plus
qu'il n'attirait il y a quelques années
qui est plutôt une bonne nouvelle euh
mais pour le reste le gros c'est
l'interface avec ce qui se passe à
Bruxelles dans les négociations de de
tous les toutes les directives et puis
dans dans ce que sont les grandes
politiques notamment la politique
agricole commune et puis après c'est
l'interface avec le ministère de
l'écologie le ministère de la Santé
enfin un certain nombre de ministère
dans lequel on a voilà donc comme vous
j'observe que c'est pas complètement
apaisé et comme vous j'observe que
parfois c'est long et et peu efficace
moi je fais pas de commentaire sur le
ministre je je ne les choisis pas je
travaille avec et ensuite je relève ou
pas la possibilité d'obtenir des
résultats mais en tous les cas il nous
faut il nous faut un il nous faut un
ministère de tutelle ça me paraît
essentiel et dans le moment dans lequel
on est ça me paraît encore plus évident
euh sur le sur l'agribashing bon écoutez
d'abord ce que j'observe c'est que il
est moins important que ce qu'on avait
il y a 3 ou 4 ans que les juges ont fait
ce qu'il fallait pour que les gens qui
s'autorisent à envahir des élevages
comme ça dans des conditions euh enfin
comme si on rentrait chez vous bon tout
ça est en train de se tarer il y a
quelques amendes un peu un peu calibré
qui ont été enfin il y a des jugements
en tous les cas qui ont été rendus qui
ont dissuadé de de de de ce type
d'action bon c'est c'est pas
complètement terminé hein l'état voilà
mais enfin bon on onévitera jamais
quelques quelques excessifs euh mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que ça laissait des
traces et la question
euh du du bien-être en agriculture c'est
une question centrale alors on travaille
maintenant avec Monsieur damzin enfin
Monsieur cel faisait référence à ce qui
avait été fait mais voilà c'est un sujet
qui doit se poursuivre et qui et qui
fait sur lequel on a encore beaucoup de
beaucoup de travail et d'une manière
générale c'est ça rejoint le sujet de de
de de la santé mentale qui est un sujet
qui dépasse le C agricole je le dis
aussi he très largement et qui nous et
qui nous préoccupe sur les sujets alors
élevage réglementation bien oui mais là
aussi je voudrais être on voit comme
vous la décapitalisation de l'élevage et
singulièrement de l'élevage laitier il
nous reste aujourd'hui moins de 50000
éleveurs laitiers en France
et attirer des jeunes aujourd'hui on
leur expliquant que même avec un robot
de traite c'est quand même une astreinte
importante avec les l'évolution de la
société c'est pas naturel même quand
vous êtes fils d'éleveur et que vous
aimez ce métier et que vous avez bercé
dedans c'est pas complètement évident
parce que la vie sociale parce que la
volonté d'avoir aussi une vie comme tous
les Français de votre âge n'adhère pas
le consentement immédiat et et ça pose
aussi la question de la taille et moi je
je je pense qu'il faut pas du tout
éluder ce sujet demain des tailles
d'élevage plus importante et j'ai pas
dit des tailles d'élevage voilà mais des
des tailles d'élevage plus importantes
ça permet des associations ça permet du
salariat et ça permet de pouvoir
profiter d'un weekend de temps en temps
d'un peu de repos ou de quelques jours
de vacances ce ce sujet il est il est
important dans la question euh de de
l'élevage
euh sur la réglementation j'en ai
largement parlé euh quand enfin un
ministère de la simplification écoutez
moi je je laisse ça à qui de droit moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
obtient comme résultat et qu'est-ce
qu'on est capable euh rapidement de
faire sauter je note que chaque
gouvernement qui cesse explique que dans
sa période d'évolution il a pris x texte
x loi voilà donc on pèse au kilo on
travaille au kilo aujourd'hui très bien
moi j'aimerais qu'à un moment on puisse
dire aussi que la qualité passe par la
modération voyez et que et qu'on puisse
faire en sorte que de temps en temps on
se dise qu'il y a peut-être des choses
un peu à à nettoyer un peu comme chez
vous quand vous faites le grand ménage
et vous ouvrez des placards et vous
découvrez des choses que vous n'avez pas
utilisé depuis des années voilà donc on
a besoin besoin de cet exercice voilà
après chacun reste dans son couloir de
nage moi je sais pas si c'est un
ministère si c'est un haut commissaire
si c'est un secréta je ne sais pas ce
que je sais c'est qu'on attend des
résultats sur nos
fermes concernant
la la question du du sénateur salmon
alors là aussi le 2080 sur les zpac
c'est en Europe ça n'est pas le cas en
France donc non mais faut faut qu'on
soit précis voilà donc je vous donne le
chiffre en France c'est 80 % des aides
pour 47 % des agriculteurs voilà donc je
compte sur vous maintenant
pour pour porter cette cette
information je redis comme je l'avais
dit au début vous avez aussi 100000
agriculteurs qui font moins de 25000 €
de production brute standard c'est pas
mes chiffres he c'est les chiffres de la
nation ils sont vérifiables évidemment
et donc vous voyez bien que aussi ça en
terme de volume d'aide voilà ça peut pas
être ça peut pas être comparable vous
posiez la question euh de la
redistribution mais est-ce qu'on reste à
l'hctare ou pas mais je je vais y venir
je vais venir euh la question de la
redistribution donc au moment où je vous
parle la PAC prévoit déjà un volet de
redistribution puisque euh il y a
euh une surprime sur les premiers
hectares 52 premiers hectares enfin bon
c'était un débat politique j'y reviens
pas mais en tous les cas il y a il y a
une une aide supérieure euh pour les les
les premiers hectares ensuite sur les
aides à l'hectare aujourd'hui c'est le
modèle européen il y avait eu des
questions sur l'aide à à l'actif qui ont
été soulevé pourquoi pourquoi la France
n'a pas enfin tout pourquoi la fnsoa je
me contenter de mon rôle pourquoi la
FNSA n'a pas assumé ça parce que quand
vous regardez les chiffres aujourd'hui
si on prend ce modèle ceux qu'ont des
actifs ce sont les Roumains ce sont les
Bulgares ce sont des pays qui
aujourd'hui capteraient une part
importante du soutien sur cette base
c'est un débat qu'on a déjà eu des
dizaines de fois y compris à Bruxells
donc après on peut dire on bascule à
l'actif
voilà je je en tous les cas quand ça a
été fait la dernière fois ce sujet
conduisait à un transfert massif vers
les gens qui sont encore
très très structuré en main d'œuvre
moins automatisé moins voilà et donc
très clairement on avait un transfert
assez massif voilà après l'aide à
l'hctare vous savez le sujet c'est
toujours de faire bouger les lignes tout
le monde dit B on a qu'à rayer la Pâque
et on va la réécrire quand je vois la
difficulté qu'on a eu à Bruxelles mais
vous aviez un député européen à côté de
vous donc il vous le dira la difficulté
à Bruxelles de de trouver un compromis
entre États-membres avec une fois encore
un niveau de subsidiarité qu'on avait
jamais vu dans les précédentes réformes
de la PAC évidemment ça nous questionne
nous ça nous questionne nous mais on l'a
écrit on l'a dit voilà et il y avait à
l'époque la promesse que les PSN donc
les projets stratégiques nationaux
seraient comparés politiquement entre je
suis au regret de constater que ça n'a
pas été le cas mais c'était l'engagement
qui était pris voilà et ça c'est pas
voilà donc
aujourd'hui d'abord un certain nombre
d'étatmembres étaient très en retard la
réforme s'est fait très dans la enfin en
tous les cas à la fin dans la
précipitation tout le monde rendait on
essaie d'aller nous on demandait qu'on
puisse avoir les règles parce qu'il y
avait aussi des règles d'application de
la PAC et d'ailleurs dont on découvre
quelques écueils aujourd'hui puisqueau
moment où je vous parle une de nos
demandes là c'est que les 5 à 7 % de
dossiers qui ne sont pas ou pas
partiellement réglé puisse l'être et on
découvre quelques écueils je vous en
donne un il était prévu que pour éviter
que des gens puissent bénéficier d'être
PAC jusqu'à 80 ans 90 ans voilà on est à
partir de des régimes de retraite voilà
le fait qu'on puisse plus toucher d' PAC
et là qu'est-ce qu'on constate on
constate que quelques dossiers de gens
qui parce que par exemple la conjointe a
travaillé dans la fonction publique
hospitalière par exemple les trois qu
premières années de sa vie elle a
aujourd'hui 64 ou 65 ans son régime est
purgé automatiquement elle touche 120 €
par mois ou 100 € par mois ou 80 € de de
de sa période de travail de quelques
années au début de sa carrière et là
poum il y a plus d' pack voilà et là on
dit bah non c'est pas l'esprit du texte
là on dit bah oui mais on sait pas
comment on va faire fa qu'on le fasse à
la main voilà bon je je je vous dis ça
aussi parce que derrière et je fais
référence à ce qui a été dit c'est des
hommes et des femmes voilà c'est pas que
des machines et de l'argent et voilà
donc il y a des gens aujourd'hui qui
sont dans dans la panade euh donc la
distribution je vous ai parlé sur
euh sur les les les accords commerciaux
et le fait que il y a quelques
entreprises vous avez cité saintventia
moi je n'en cite pas parce que en fait
ce qui m'intéresse c'est pas le le nchem
c'est l'efficacité du dispositif euh
voilà nous on a besoin encore une fois
et je le dis ici parce que souvent on
explique que l'industrie l'agroindustrie
c'est pas bien puis alors moi je sais de
quoi je parle euh voilà quand on a 1 lre
de lait quand vous avez une brique de
lait quand vous avez 1 kil de farine
quand vous avez une bouteille d'huile
sur votre table elle est pas arrivée du
champ de l'agriculteur ou de ou de la
stabulation elle est pas arrivée
directement sur votre table et donc on a
besoin de partenairire industriel non
mais je je le dis c'est pas évident pour
tout le monde donc h les fruits et
légumes et le miel tout a à peu près
besoin de passer entre les mains d'une
industrie alors je sais que l'industrie
c'est pas très moderne en France
aujourd'hui mais enfin nous on en a
besoin voilà bon donc ce qui nous
intéresse c'est non mais oui mais vous
voyez bien le sujet le sujet c'est la
marge vous avez raison monsieur le
sénateur non mais vous critique pas moi
j'entends toute la journée que parce que
au titre de la profession agricole je
préside un groupe industriel qui
transforme nos graines de cols tournesol
en huile je serai le représentant du du
grand capital je me permets devant les
représentants de la nation que vous êtes
de d'éclaircir le point voilà et donc ce
qui m'intéresse moi ce qui m'intéresse
moi c'est de prouver que on a besoin de
transformation on a besoin que ce soit
fait en France parce que la
transformation elle peut se faire
ailleurs et revenir chez nous c'est
notamment le cas dans la la pomme de
terre quand vous êtes à la frontière
belge vous produisez les prommes de
terre la valeur ajoutée est fait en
Belgique et vous rachetez les chips en
France peut-être qu'on peut être plus
intelligent que ça et se dire que on
fait ça je dis ça parce que le sujet
c'est pas telle ou telle entreprise
c'est c'est le mode de négociation et
donc là je redis ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure pour nous il faut d'abord qu'il
y a une négociation entre les
producteurs et l'industriel et
qu'ensuite en marche en marche avant on
puisse avoir la négo avec la grande
distribution ça pose aussi la question
du consentement au paiement de
l'alimentation du modèle français voilà
qui est aussi un sujet central vous ne
l'avez pas abordé je m'autorise à le
faire tout le monde nous demande
aujourd'hui de l'alimentation de qualité
de proximité et de la naturalité le
consentement au paiement je je le
constate voilà je pourrais parler de
l'agriculture biologique qui traverse
une crise majeure majeure parce que
aujourd'hui le marché en tous les cas la
demande n'est pas là et qu'on se bat à
la FNSEA pour sauver ce qu'on peut
sauver en ce moment des entreprises et
que quand on nous explique qu'il faudra
qu'on en ait quasiment le double dans 6
ans ça ne nous paraît pas raisonnable au
moment où on est dans le contexte dans
lequel on est voilà et que ce qui ce
qu'on qu'on souhaite c'est sauver les
entreprises qui aujourd'hui se posent la
question de se déconvertir et et et et
et c'est le cas et c'est le cas enfin
vous avez posé une question sur le libre
échange les accords de libre échange je
croyais que j'avais répondu je vais
essayer de préciser mon mon propos euh
nous ne sommes pas hostiles au commerce
aux échanges nous ne sommes pas pour
fermer les frontières pour les raisons
que je vous ai dit on a parlé de
viticulture tout à l'heure nous ce qui
nous inquiète c'est les sujets qui
concernent la réciproc
ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui c'est que
de mettre des clauses de sauvegarde qui
sont juridiquement costaud de mettre des
normes de réciprocité ce qu'on a appelé
les clos miroir à Bruxelles qui sont
quand même un peu compliqués à mettre en
œuvre un peu compliqué à mettre en œuvre
et enfin les contrôles qui sont quasi
inexistants sur l'importation des
denrées alimentaires moins de 3 % de ce
qui rentre en denrées alimentair en
Europe fait l'objet de contrôle nous
questionne voilà ce qu'on dit après moi
je suis pas à les douanes je voilà et
puis je suis pas compétent pour en
parler je dis juste que il y a une vraie
appréhension de ça maintenant moi en
tant que consommateur demander de la
mozzarella italienne ou un bout de
serérano espagnol ou de boire un café le
matin ça me pose pas de problème et donc
expliquer qu'on va produire du café en
France demain est pas complètement
réaliste donc voilà j'essaie de j'essaie
pardon
oui mais voilà vous avez on sait faire
plein de choses même du jambon on sait
le faire aussi hein voilà mais mais
acceptons qu'il puisse y avoir aussi
d'autres produits qui font une
alimentation de qualité
voilà merci monsieur le Président alors
Guilin Cambier Jean-Marc Boyer
Antoinette Gul Guilin merci Madame la
Président je vais essayer d'être rapide
et le plus court possible je me suis
rendu comme beaucoup d'entre nous sur
les points de
blocage de nos exploitants agricoes j'ai
des questions tant philosophiques que
que pratiques d'abord très pratique au
pratique j'ai entendu beaucoup de la
part des des exploitants trois choses
revenir ou ressortir les lourdeurs
administratives françaises les loi
l'application de la loi égalim et les
normes euh est-ce que sur ces ces points
là par exemple vous avez eu de puuisque
vous échang vous êtes en échange continu
avec le gouvernement depuis la semaine
passée est-ce que vous avez eu des
avancées concrètes 2è 2è question
euh un peu un peu plus générale la PAC
qui était une véritable réussite
européenne et qui était un marqueur de
la construction
européenne provoque en effit un certain
nombre de de questionnement est-ce que
vous pensez que la vision européenne de
l'agriculture est telle qu'elle est
portée également par la France serait
serait à revoir et enfin 3ème question
puisque il me semble avoir constaté sur
les points de blocage des divergences de
vue on va dire ça comme ça entre les
exploitants euh euh agricoles comment
est-ce que vous la Fédération vous
essayez de porter l'unicité du mouvement
et de la parole agricole merci Jean-Marc
oui merci euh merci monsieur le
Président pour votre pour votre présence
euh sur le terrain effectivement on
rencontre des agriculteurs qui sont
excédés excédé par des règles
incohérentes irrité par des excès de aè
de l'administration qui fait appliquer
des des consignes qui ne sont pas du
tout qui sont totalement incohérentes
par des des fonctionnaires zés dans la
proposition de loi de mon collègue
Laurent Duplan répondre à la crise
agricole euh il est proposé la
suppression de l'fb est-ce que quel
quelle est votre position par rapport à
cette à cette proposition qui me paraît
euh très très importante dans le cadre
euh des des euh motivations que peuvent
avoir les agriculteurs actuellement 2è
question euh on parle beaucoup des
règles de surtransposition euh en France
j'ai pas souvenir moi d'avoir voté des
règles de surtransposition dans notre
assemblée euh donc qui décide
aujourd'hui d'après vous de ces règles
de surtransposition qui sont appliquées
effectivement et qui posent de réels
problèmes 3è question j'ai été très
choqué de voir des blindés face au
tracteur euh on a connu les émetiers en
cagoulet qui cassaient tout dans les
rues de Paris et ailleurs avec des tirs
de mortiers sur les forces sur les
forces de l'ordre et les agriculteurs
sont des gens quand même raisonnables or
le symbole est quand même fort et je
trouve complètement déplacé donc quel
est votre sentiment par rapport à à
cette à cette opération Antoinette Gul
oui madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la FNA moi ma question va
porter sur les pesticides en 2021
l'incerne donc l'Institut nationale de
la santé et de la recherche a rendu
public un rapport euh qui un rapport sur
l'effet des pesticides démontrant qu'il
y a un lien entre l'exposition aux
pesticides et euh la santé des
agriculteurs et la survenu notamment de
trois types de cancer le cancer de la
prostate le miélome multiple et le
lymphome
noncnien donc ma question est la
suivante la lutte contre les pesticides
chimiques devrait être un combat commun
que vous devriez porter au côté des
écologistes euh que nous sommes je
voulais savoir quel était votre
positionnement sur ce point précis car
nous voyons que les premières victimes
des pesticides ce sont les agriculteurs
ensuite bien sûr les citoyens je vous
remercie voilà c'est à vous monsieur le
Président merci madame la Présidente
donc sur la question du du sénateur
Combier donc sur les les lourdeurs les
normes bon vous avez raison he c'est ce
qui aujourd'hui a été le le déclencheur
bon au moment où je vous parle je n'ai
pas de certitude qui ont été annoncé par
le Premier ministre et ses services nous
on a dit ce qu'on souhaitait voilà sur
un certain nombre de de de de de
surtransposition qu'elle soit d'origine
enfin qu'elle soit faite sur le plan
européen avec des règles européennes
qu'on qu' qu'on surtranspose en France
hein notamment sur les pesticides mais
on en dira un mot je vais vous répondre
madame et et puis sur toutes les normes
bon je vous ai parlé de la laine de
mouton mais je je peux vous en voilà le
sujet en fait ce qui est difficile c'est
c'est c'est le changement de culture
c'estàd que moi je fais pas de
commentaire sur les fonctionnaires je
pense que les fonctionnaires ils font le
boulot qu'on leur demande de faire
est-ce qu'on est capable à un moment de
dire qu'à chaque fois qu'on met quelque
chose on puisse un l'étalonner et dire
qu'est-ce que ça remplace voilà si on
dit bah il faut tel type de norme
qu'est-ce qu'on de quoi on a plus besoin
et comment on le fait on ne se pose
jamais la question et en fait ce qui est
difficile mais l'administration
elle-même parfois se retrouve avec des
grilles de lecture qui font que ce n'est
pas les mêmes en fonction des
départements donc c'est ça qui nous
questionne et nous on dit mais il y a un
moment il faut faire simple j'avais pris
mais je me rappelle monsieur le sénateur
on avait parlé des e ensemble la
question de la ha c'est
c'est question un peu voilà tout le
monde dit ça a du sens il faut en mettre
voilà bon
14 12 ou 14 parties texte règlement qui
vont dessus niveau européen quand on
parle Directive Habitat quand on parle
directive oiseau niveau français date on
touche pas une voilà bon et on comprend
pas pourquoi les agriculteurs veulent
pas EMP planter donc moi j'ai essayé de
faire l'exégèse j'ai essayé d'expliquer
qu'à un moment quand vous n'en avez pas
et que vous avez pas d'ennui vous avez
pas forcément envie de vous en créer
alors que pour autant sur le plan
agronomique ou de la biodiversité ça
peut avoir du puis après on peut même
parler de de l'intérêt économique de lae
comment avec une e deain on peut
produire de la biomasse on peut faire
des choses mais il faut il faut que
voilà mais il faut que tout ça ce cadre
avec des filières aujourd'hui on est
incapable de parler de ça incapable de
parler de ça voilà donc nous on essaie
d'avancer le Premier ministre a annoncé
que il ferait un seul texte alors moi je
sais pas si c'est un seul qui reprend
les 14 ou si voilà donc on a très envie
de discuter du contenu au moment où je
vous parle je ne sais pas de quoi je
parle donc j'ai entendu l'annonce mais
bon donc tout ce qui sera de nature à
nous faciliter la vie il ira dans le bon
sens je redis pour éviter les excès on n
pas dit que il y avait plus de norme
qu'on a pas dit qu'il y avait plus voilà
pour cette audition d'Arnaud Rousseau le
président de la FNSEA qui était reçu
auditionné ce matin par la commission
des affaires économiques du Cénat une
audition que vous avez pu suivre en
direct sur notre antenne depuis 11h le
président du premier syndicat agricole
de France qui a dit que l'attente des
agriculteurs était énorme je cite
peut-être au-delà de ce que l'on imagine
fin de citation le présid prident de la
FNSEA s'est dit disposé à travailler les
mesures du gouvernement point par point
autre grand enjeu les questions
européennes car beaucoup de sujets vont
se jouer à Bruxelles notamment demain
avec un Conseil européen dédié aux
questions agricoles n'hésitez pas à lire
les décryptages à voir les replays c'est
sur
publicsenat.fr pour ma part je vous
retrouve avec Tam tranui à partir de
14h50 sur Public Sénat pour suivre le
discours de politique générale de
Gabriel hatal après celui de l'Assemblée
nationale hier tout de suite vous avez
rendez-vous avec Orian manchini dans
bonjour chez
[Musique]
vous